qui est l'imposteur Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que c'est possible ou est-ce que
c'est impossible sur je pense que les
gens rêveraient tellement c'est
sensationnel genre what the fuck tu as
deux candidat de la présidence qui qui
joue ensemble dans un jeu mais bien sûr
que non c'est pas quelque chose que tu
imagines d ré bah je pense c'est
compliqué de mêler des candidats à des
élections présidentielles à nos formats
nous qui touchons beaucoup de jeunes et
tout enfin je je je sais pas moi je je
Seris un peu mal à l'aise au passage on
voit vraiment la ressemblance mais c'est
vrai que il y a une ressemblance avec
Emmanuel Macon